6 26 into wednesday morning hey we're
learning an
unfortunate term from the road rage
dictionary a viewer email about rude
drivers james writes hey i drive safely
and courteously not too slow not too
fast i go with the flow obey the laws
but this seems to have made me the
target of aggressive dangerous behavior
from harassing threatening drivers of
big trucks
with big wheels he writes i've been
flipped off
cut off charged from behind tailgated
with only inches between vehicles
and he's even had to take evasive action
but then james threw in a term
i had not heard before he says he has
been coal
rolled i looked it up wikipedia says
rolling coal is the practice of
modifying a diesel engine to put out
large amounts of black or gray [ __ ]
exhaust fumes
on the cars behind you james concludes
please tell me that somebody at metro or
nhp is aware that this is happening
and that they're at least trying to
catch some of these boneheads
well i am passing your email along james
thanks for taking the time to write in
buckle up drive carefully and please
put down that phone if there is
something driving you crazy email me
traffic 8 8newsnow.com